[Music]
Richard I did want to put question about
the banks to you because it's widely
being reported that if Jeremy Corbyn
becomes Prime Minister then essentially
he and John McDonald have their targets
on the City of London and this is
basically going to cause a huge collapse
in the way in which we have operated and
financed large parts of the British
economy for years to come
is there a way in which a Labour
government really can put forward a
responsible and meaningful way of
dealing with the financial sector or are
you due to basically scare them out of
existence we're not trying to scare
anybody are you're succeeding we're not
trying to with the help of the
newspapers we're not trying to scare
people at all but I think what gotz
understand is whilst the financial
sector plays a vital vital role in our
economy you can get to the stage where
it's bringing a disproportionate role in
our economy
and that doesn't help for the more equal
distribution in creation of wealth right
across the country when people are
analyzing why certain communities voted
to leave the European Union it's almost
a if you laid out on a map it's often
these areas which feel economically a
left behind haven't shared in the wealth
from the reliance upon the financial
services but I do want to quickly about
something at least said if that's okay I
tomb against rigged markets and when I
speak out against free market
fundamentalism
maybe I should correct myself because
what the conservators in government
really produce is risk-free capitalism
for big business in my own area in
probation for example probation was part
privatized by Chris Grayling people know
that his long list of fails across
government but that was against all the
advice but the state under conservative
stewardship was basically funneling
loads and loads of cash five hundred
million pounds extra to failing private
firms so actually in that sense it's not
a free market if these companies succeed
they get the plaudits and keep the
profits if they do badly you and bail
amounts that's the Richard I wanted to
list but I should put it anyone who's
ever visited prisons like Wormwood
Scrubs
Pentonville we shall tell you that
state-run prisons aren't necessarily
particularly fantastic either well you
mentioned the issue of parts of the
industrial north of England becoming
disillusioned but one of the things
they've become disillusioned with is a
Labour Party I think the 2017 election
was not a resounding success for the
Conservatives
but it was interesting that we did win
seats like Middlesbrough and Derbyshire
northeast and it's because people in
those areas by a large work in private
sector companies they want to get on in
life they believe in enterprise and
we've got a party in the labour party
that is fundamentally anti that and
there is an issue you cannot have decent
public services if you don't have a
strong free enterprise economy and we've
got a Shadow Chancellor who's talking
about not just nationalizing and energy
companies but nationalizing them not at
market value so essentially
appropriating property and that is why
people are scared people are scared of
fundamentally undermining the ideas of
property rights on which our prosperity
as a country is based in which to take
that very seriously we can see what's
happened around the world when that
principle has been eroded for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute's of Arts and
ideas her III TV
you